فوضى عارمه في علامات التوثيق الزرقاء
تسببت بها منصه تويتر منذ ان بدات تطبيق
قرارها بازاله العلامه عن كل من يرفض
الدفع مقابل منح تلك الاشاره التي لطالما
كان الحصول عليها متعبا لمن يدفع بعض
الدولارات بينما لم يكن بمقدور اي شخص كان
الحصول عليها قبل استحواذ الى ماسك عليها
وبعد تطبيق القرار باتا يصعب التفريق بين
الحسابات القديمه الموثقه لشخصيات عامه
مثل باراك اوباما وحسابات التوثيق
المدفوعه شهريا وبالتالي قلل القرار من
قيمه تلك العلامه وفقا لخبراء بمنصات
التواصل الاجتماعي بالمقابل اعلن الكثير
من الشخصيات الشهيره ومنهم نجم كره السله
الامريكيه ليبرون جيمس وصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز انهم لن يدفعوا اشتراكا مقابله
تحويل علامه الطائر على صفحتهم من اللون
الابيض الى اللون الازرق لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات